this video is sponsored by Asus what's
up guys we're talking Sony a7r5 now
myself and Zaki actually went to a
motorcycle show tested out in low light
performance seeing how it tracks on
motorcycles how it detects them how it
handles a low light eight stops image
stabilization then we took it to an
arcade to try out the auto focusing why
an arcade a lot of lights a lot of
distractions to see how well it picked
up people you know little spoiler alert
it blew our minds if you want to know
what i'm recording on right now it is
the Sony a7r5 8K 25p ISO set at 640 this
is absolutely beautiful video quality a
lot of people are saying this is not a
video camera I'm going to disagree I'm
going to say this is a pretty damn good
video camera as a matter of fact after
this short clip we'll come back and I'll
show you what it looks like in 4k 50 as
well with pixel bidding to see if you
can tell the difference anyway enjoy
what we experienced with the a7r5
dude
that lady in the mask with a green shirt
is getting the eyeball
come on
dude this is not even fun anymore this
might be the best auto focusing I've
seen in a mirrorless camera right now I
mean I'm used to Sony being good
and I'm used to Canon being good and
Nikon is also really good right now
especially with the z9 this got a
separate processor just for the
autofocus
and it's AI so it learns that's what
that Sony's saying
this thing is grabbing on the eyes and
people
where I've never seen a camera do this
before holy
and things have changed
he's doing a sniper pose
you don't need to do that man the Ibis
is good enough just shoot
zachy's experiencing what I'm
experiencing right now it is
this good
I thought a lot of these reviewers are
just full of BS you know like normally
you know some or Sony Fanboys I get it I
like Sony too but some of them really
get into this
but this autofocus is not good the
feeling of that Cliff yes
yes
but do you see the focusing
this makes it
so it's great
photography I mean it's not
profile but let's get out of the arcades
let's go check out some bikes all right
then of course because now
you can choose cars check out the
YouTubers trains
and different subjects right here right
so you can try it r1m
testing the new camera right yeah A7 R5
just grabs it man
it feels more solid I don't know what it
is maybe it's just the way the
construction is because it's got this
basically fully articulating screen but
it just feels very solid this screen
right here it's the best thing Sony's
put out
on a camera in years look at this
tilt it this way down like that
rotate it
we can do everything with this damn
thing it's like a jigsaw puzzle evf is
insane it's a 9.44 million dot evf it's
bright it's clear
I mean it's dark here I look in this it
feels like it's like daylight almost
it's so bright in this thing I don't
even I don't know if I can show it to
you can you get the camera close to it
it's really bright
this is a fantastic evf
guys can probably thoughts one over five
and it's tack Sharp Zaki when is the
last time you've used a Sony camera one
over five and got a sharp shot without a
tripod it doesn't happen
doesn't happen
they've finally done it they've given us
the Ibis we have been waiting for on one
over five at F 1.4 my ISO is 250. I'm
gonna get a clean shot in low light
hey Baron in this situation what do you
think my shutter speed is to get you
sharp table one over 100. take a look at
the shop tell me what you think
oh you're sharp right oh yeah one over
ten oh my God
now you're still going to get a little
bit of noise it's low light I'm putting
I'm your backlight on this as well and
I'm still getting him sharp so very time
to shift forward
I tell you
impressive right I wasn't expecting that
with this camera I was seeing some of
the reviews that some of you guys have
seen as well hearing about the eye
business that it's that much better one
over ten with a 135 handheld
and sharp
this could be Sony's best photo camera
to date
I'm going to say that is right now but
you know what that means the Alpha One
Mark II whatever they're going to call
it
holy cow I think it's gonna be a beast
how are you going to decide
I wouldn't I'll be screwed this video is
brought to you by Asus check out the
Asus Zenbook 14x OLED Space Edition
commemorating the 25th anniversary of
the first Asus laptop sent into space
Not only does it offer a space exclusive
design but it's even worthy of going
where no man has gone before with its
space grade durability it even comes
with a 3.5 inch OLED companion Zen
Vision display and you will have a ball
of time taking interviews with a 16 by
10 4K OLED Nano Edge Pantone validated
14 inch display so as you just saw right
there this camera is really impressive
honestly speaking this is probably my
favorite Sony camera when it comes to
photography to date for now we shot in
raw now there is no raw conversion in
Lightroom as of yet so we had to convert
it in Tiff but the colors coming out of
this I had to do very minimal editing to
get to the colors I wanted and usually
with Sony cameras that takes a little
bit of work but not with the a7r5 now
right now I'm actually recording in 4k
50p with that pixel bidding that
everybody's talking about and let me ask
you a question honestly speaking how
does image quality look I'm using the
same lens the same 24 to 70 F 2.8 gm2
lens from Sony how does this image
quality look it is stunning out of this
camera even with pixel binning it's
going to look good Sony knows what
they're doing I see a lot of reviewers
out there talking about this stuff going
like look it's got pixel binning hair
and this and this and let me tell you
something when you get the compression
of YouTube and Facebook and Instagram
let's say a movie theater yeah that's
when you're gonna notice these things
but on this format you're not anyway I
digress this camera is fantastic it
doesn't have 4K 120 but outside of that
this is a very formidable camera for
videographers and for photographers out
there and it's my favorite Sony camera
to date I think even surpassing the
Alpha One this Auto focusing chip is
friggin phenomenal anyway those are my
thoughts on the camera let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below
are you looking to pick up an a7r5 any
questions I'll try to answer them for
you if you like this video check out
more of our reviews right here